on retiendra du voyage de lapierre ces
images de marigny des pieds dans l'eau
et tirant à bout de bras la tout pour
éviter les bancs de sable
même si l'activité a beaucoup évolué
avec la présence d'un moteur
les mariniers doivent toujours composer
avec des éléments et le relief oui
quelques passages un peu compliqué comme
le comme certains ponts à amboise où à
blois où effectivement il ya beaucoup de
beaucoup de cailloux au milieu et puis
démarche qui sont à ses hôtes avec des
grosses vagues quand même le fleuve
n'est plus vraiment navigables comme
d'antan quoi aujourd'hui on fonctionne
beaucoup à moteur aussi ce qui fait une
grosse différence
après quatre jours de navigation à
raison de 30 heures par jour
des visages sont buriné les corps
endolori le voyage de la pierre reste
une expérience humaine
je suis tombé dans l'eau tout petit déjà
alors oui mais sur la loi cette année et
vous porter la barbe comme les anciens
bas depuis que j'ai cassé mon rasoir à
25 ans oui quel est l'autre point commun
avec les mariniers d'antan mariniers
d'antan mais c'est le désir d'être sur
la loire la précieuse cargaison le bloc
de tuffeau 60 à 80 kg est porté par des
marines sous le regard émerveillé et les
acclamations du public
restait encore un dernier geste
symbolique glisser dans la pierre
quelques souvenirs d'aujourd'hui nous
mettrons deux petites médailles frappées
cette année à l'occasion des 500 ans du
château avec la monnaie de paris
l'une qui représente le château et
l'autre le logo des festivités des 520
et nous déposerons plus symboliquement
le nom de l'ensemble de mes collègues
238 non tout le personnel de chambord
qui a été si mobilisé cette année pour
les 500 ans de ce château merveilleux et
le nom aussi de toutes les associations
les villes les institutions qui ont
rendu possible ce voyage de la pierre
aux costumes d'époque
les enfants ont rendu un vibrant hommage
en chansons aux mariniers si courageux
[Musique]